à à propos de gloire son oeuvre à
peut-être sonné pour le groupe de rock
français indochine indochine va-t-il
supplanter téléphone dans le coeur des
jeunes amateurs de rock français ces
deux groupes se disputent depuis
plusieurs mois la première place dans le
palmarès des ventes de disques téléphone
est toujours en tête mais ses rivaux
sont en train de gagner du terrain
indochine déjà récolté trois disques
d'or et vient de sortir un nouvel album
le troisième sexe et surtout ils font
salle comble au zénith ou ce soir 6000
jeune moyenne d'âge 15 ans sont allés
les écouter ils jouent à guichet fermé
pour quatre représentations
hélène risacher on revient tout juste à
lui c'est stéphane du groupe indochine
en direct de dix années bonsoir c'est de
munich
bonsoir c'est dit
salut c'est nicolas et partenaires de
chine
laquelle m
key
vous venez de sortir une chanson qui
s'appelle le troisième sexe qu'est ce
que ça veut dire pour c'est un message
hautement philosophique indispensable
lancé histoire de dire qu' on en avait
marre et que je pense que la plupart des
jeunes comme nous on en a marre de se
faire montrer du doigt quand on est
habillé un peu différemment et que les
gens qui montrent du doigt sont déjà un
peu pervers cas tolérant donc c'est une
chanson sur la tolérance à paris ça peut
être révolu mais en province encore
quand on voit les gosses sont les choux
rouges et un peu maquillée souricieuses
mal que ça serait bête curieuse village
c'est un peu toutes ces choses là et ces
gens là qui monte de ces gosses la dudh
ouais c'est vrai tu es et plus bizarre
c'est le temps qui sont appelés chance
pas courir chez eux
quand on dit avec vous tout le monde à
14 ans qu'est ce que vous en pensez
bah ça tant mieux parce qu'on s'aperçoit
que c'est ce contretemps qui sont à nos
concerts qui bouge qui tapent des mains
et qui applaudissent qui chante avec
nous donc si tout le monde avait 14 ans
au vrai dire tout le monde à cette
insouciance et cette qualité c'est très
bien
on est conscient que on peut pas on va
pas faire une chanson contre le chômage
parce que ça serait difficile de votre
côté mais on peut très bien se battre
contre le racisme se battre contre la
faim dans le monde sait ce qu'on a fait
vous pensez que ça peut être efficace
aux gens d'en bas si on le ferait pas je
vois pas enfin je veux dire que fassi
tous les artistes déjà le fond c'est
simple c'est bien il ya plein de
bénévoles qui le font mais bon ici
il se trouve que les artistes ont une
image médiatique donc on s'en sert pour
eux pour faire des concerts comme à la
concorde il ya un an comme tout ça quoi
tu
vous les gars